[Music]
Stephanie what are you doing I'm
manually making a copy my data in case
my database goes down you don't need to
do that by hand here let me show you how
to set up high availability alright
thank goodness let's take a quick look
at what happens with a highly available
configuration using my sequel the
primary instance and failover replicas
are in two separate zones as updates are
made to the primary instance that
replicated to the failover if the
primary instance goes down cloud sequel
will make sure the failover is
up-to-date and then promote it to the
primary instance this is what it looks
like when the failover happens instead
of manually making any application
changes cloud sequel moves the primary
IP address over so the same database
connection information will work it
looks a little different for Postgres
but you still get seamless failover so
not only does cloud sequel manage my
database it can actually handle my
primary database going down to that's
right now that we've seen how it happens
on the back end let's take a look at how
to set it up by going to the cloud
sequel instances page we can see our
currently running databases looking at
needs failover you can click the Add
button under high availability to set up
and automatically manage replicas we'll
go ahead and call it needs failover
failover and hit the create button this
will create the failover for you now if
we're gonna create a new database the
first thing we can do is choose between
my sequel or Postgres so we'll click on
create instance will choose my sequel
we'll choose second generation and we're
gonna go ahead and give it a name we'll
call it my new DB don't forget to secure
it with a secure root password then
we'll go to the high availability
section and we'll make sure binary
logging this is for my sequel is checked
off and click create failover replica
we'll go ahead and then click the create
button and we're good to go now once
these fail overs are created the other
thing we're able to do is test out a
failover
so if we actually go to one that already
has it set up click in on that and then
go to the top right where it says
failover this will let you actually
execute the failover now you can see how
easy it is to make your
sequel instances highly available so if
the primary instance is down due to
being patched or for any other reason we
have a replica set up and ready to go
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content
[Music]